bonjour c'est thomas ngijol pour bruce
n'a pas vraiment envie de dire mange ton
cul à nos journalistes qui te dit ça
puisque usain bolt offs et brut on n'est
pas bruxelles brut on évoque même pas
[Musique]
ce
s'engager contre le racisme truc je
m'engage donc la jument d'âge mais trop
c'est trop
un [ __ ] de merde je sais pas ce que ça
veut dire s'engager contre le racisme se
rend compte et des associations
d'engagement comptera six touche pas à
mon pote avec ses et des écharpes le
petit moment c'est un super mec et moi
je resterai pas tomber la sphère moment
avec toi actuellement il est en prison
on va faire une un conte litchi pour que
il sera jugé comme n'importe quel
citoyen français posture ça suffit cette
situation a trop duré
touche pas à mon pote julien dray bah ça
c'est pour réduire ça c'est vraiment la
question pour réduire ton narquois pour
dire tu es drôle mais on va quand même
te laisser dans la case mauriste pour
pour les noirs pour les arabes pour les
chinois mais nous on a envie de rester
entre blanc tu comprends en fait tourner
humour tu touche à des choses
en fait on s'y attendait pas vraiment et
ça nous fait chier donc la bonne
technique c'est dans une question de
réduire ton à ses ça en fait
pour les notaires ça veut rien dire
c'est débile j'ai grandi ici j'ai les
codes d'ici et la chance dehors d'autres
codes je peux pas faire semblant de les
oublier
g
maison rigide c'est comme ça concernant
souvent les gens dans certains types
il ya un côté un peu condescendant par
moments il faudrait faut souvent montrer
patte blanche montrer le truc un peu qui
va plaire là à une certaine élite
blanche à voir le tampon les antilles
n'est pas agressif il fera rien c'est le
canton sécurité peut encore au salon
mais c'est subtil c'est très subtil et
je vous dis ça consomme très peu de gens
en feu mais c'est des petits gens qui
des fois mettre des petits poissons
[Musique]
pour un point d'accord j'y vais ce
marchent marchent pendant des heures
seul souvent sans chaussures je suis
dans ce petit village au sud du calmant
c'est la nature c'est deschamps en
simple c'est des valeurs qui me bats
pour nous est ce que vous savez
l'afrique est connu pour réparer les
dérives de nos occidentaux ne fait qu on
part en couilles c'est bien connu qu'on
en afrique et en asie j'ai déconné
contre le bus
ces gens qui n'avaient rien qu'il était
à même le sol avant de leur petit boui
boui leur manque
j'ai su que je faisais fausse route
donc là je reviens avec beaucoup
d'intentions nabeul ça dure 24 heures
une faute bénigne ton compte twitter et
on compte instagram tu redeviens un
connard d'occident et puis c'est reparti
pour la folie mais mon rapport à
l'afrique c'est ça la spiritualité pour
moi l'un freaks
c'est un boubou en wax c'est leur
programme
affrontera en compote
ah enfin un break blanc beur ouais bah
ça c'est sûr ceux qui veulent se voiler
la face
belle expression un peu positive un peu
niaise black blanc beur on est tous
ensemble on s'adore on a pris beaucoup
de mauvaises habitudes aussi beaucoup il
ya eu trop de liberté de ton à ces
retards sur certains sujets beaucoup de
choses qu'on va se passer quand voit
dans les réseaux sociaux les excès de
certaines personnes qui dit waow irna
ils ont mal en quoi donc on peut pas
prôner le vivre ensemble sans épuré
toute la merde qui en fait la demande
heures tout ça c'est utopique scellé ce
mot d'ordre politique ou de campagne de
balle on s'en bat les steaks
ce qui ne veut pas dire que dans
l'inspiration que cela dit c'est faux
[Musique]
quand tu viens banlieue il faut
forcément un moment donné dans les
clichés on entend retourner dans sa
banlieue
faire le fameux reportage j'ai grandi là
cette balle au cinquième jeu rappelle on
joue au foot là avec les copains jusqu'à
minuit les voisins et gueuler les gosses
ont des souvenirs
il ya toujours un mois mettre dans
l'histoire on sait pas pourquoi
et mon mode habité lui au troisième jeu
il y ait syrie pour l'appeler titi sa
mère a été super gentil la main sur le
coeur on est en 2010 9 quelle fatigue